I'm home from tour I'm not well I
acquired an illness I who got take all
the sniffles in the coughs from the
later recording of this video for the
band right now look just before I went
on tour I was doing just fine I was
healthy and happy and I get to visit
Emily graslie at the Chicago Field
Museum Emily graslie is the host of the
brain scoop she and Michael Aranda
created that show here in Missoula
then it got acquired by the Chicago
Field Museum and she moved there which
was sad but it also means that she can
take me on a behind-the-scenes tour of
one of the biggest natural history
museums in the world so not so bad that
this is a single tape work yeah and so I
thought it was that is wrapped around a
metal plate if you have a tapeworm and
you try to get rid of it and you break
one of these segments off all of the
sexual reproductive organs are located
in the head so it will continue to
reproduce so you have to get the head
out wouldn't it be weird if our
reproductive organs were in our head
yeah oh wow that is a giant clam I need
to put a banana next to it I think it
just looks it just looks like a
normal-size to claim when I do this oh
that happened more than a pig are snakes
that's a big now I can go in the files
my hands are getting really warm
well the because they happen to expect
they might feel pretty good insulation
let's make a real one yeah it's a real
one just like the best specimens ever
collected oh man music what's this I
have a friend who's superadded diametric
jobs yeah everything this is a
fossilized pinecone what all the organic
material was replaced by limestone a
couple hundred million years old no big
deal this is the last only the only dodo
scary actually this tiny in real life
they made really good chicken nuggets
that's why Berta
yeah why not this is the egg of an
elephant bird the extinct elephant bird
it was on the island of
gasps car to give you a sense of scale I
don't have any bananas but this is an
ostrich egg and this is a real one a lot
of museums have a replica but we have an
actress is an actual act like if I drop
that then it would be like that like I
have to feel that about that first
yeah there's probably I don't know less
than half dozen of these in any museum
collection in the world don't quote me
on that I mean you could put it if
someone will tell you that I'm wrong we
take the banana for scale yeah take it
places
yeah putting put next to second but next
to thinks this is the squirrel ate a
squirrel yeah yeah every squirrel
episode the guy who who is the president
of the Museum in Berlin not only is he
married to the great great granddaughter
of Charles Darwin he also has an amazing
mustache that is like this huge swoopy
thing and I was standing over there and
the bar was here and he was standing in
front of it and his moustache perfectly
mimics it was so perfect so when I only
arrived the Field Museum she found that
there was one diorama space in the Hall
of African mammals that just wasn't was
just plywood in this wonderful beautiful
gigantic Natural History Museum and then
for some reason in the reptile room
there was a case full of African mammals
hyena so her first thought was why don't
we put those hyenas in a diorama in the
African mammals room because they're not
reptiles turns out maybe the hyenas kind
of got ignored because they're not the
most glamorous of animals but she thinks
that's unacceptable and I kind of do too
so they're doing an IndieGoGo campaign
to place the hyenas in a diorama in the
Hall of African mammals where they
belong but it's expensive so they are
offering all kinds of really amazing
perks who or it was so fantastic thank
you to all the people who came out of
the shows I hope that you had as good of
a time as I did it seemed like you did
John I will see you Oh
maybe before Tuesday Oh whoo I got this
video of Emily holding a sign
youtube.com slash brain scoop so that
you could see that it could click on
that and subscribe